I mean at least in my case the
government didn't come for me you know
at least in my case it was just Jack
Conte over in California who decided oh
I'll take this executive action to have
a sitting MP right using the authority
of a government committee to it wasn't
just rumbly there was Tick Tock Twitter
and Facebook and who knows why YouTube
just you know we I don't know that
there's something left to YouTube well
YouTube did it already but I think
that's right I guess YouTube was just or
they knew YouTube was going to play ball
right right yeah but the point is that's
I mean that's literally against the
Magna Carta that's the against the very
spirit and principle of common law and
it's staggering that that person hasn't
resigned yet right at the time of
recording that person hasn't resigned I
mean maybe they will have done by the
end of this but it's it's just so beyond
the pale and that's a member of the
conservative party you know so they've
they've bought into because I mean I
don't know what the allegations against
Russell Brand whether they're true or
not you know it's a moot point exactly
it's irrelevant right because okay well
then if he's found guilty there will be
a punishment prescribed under the law
that great then he can be punished
foreign
because actually speaking of of doing
fine you not only help me when sort of I
was waking up to this stuff and everyone
was saying you got to talk to the Sargon
of a car guy I don't even know that I
knew that you're do were you even public
at that point did I know that your name
was Carl was that even a thing probably
not you were just doing this thing okay
but then a couple years later you were
also instrumental in something else that
happened sort of accidentally because
you and I were two of the first
political guys on patreon and everyone
remembers patreon was sort of the first
crowdfund monthly donation site and uh
well I'll let you tell the story but
basically you got kicked off patreon and
it literally what happened subsequently
after that changed the trajectory of my
life so well there were a bunch of white
nationalists who really didn't like the
fact that I wasn't a white nationalist
and they were attacking me and I kind of
lost my cool on a podcast it wasn't on
my channel it was on someone else's
Channel it wasn't on my patreon or
anything like that so that wait that's a
really important point it did not occur
on your patreon what you're about to say
or your YouTube channel is being fun you
were in someone else's Channel okay yes
and they they were attacking me I lost
my call and I said things I shouldn't
have said right and I I'm you know more
than happy to accept that and looking
back at it I'm like oh but you didn't
say anything racist actually you you
said a word I was saying yeah but you
were also not using it pejoratively
really you were using it in like sort of
like a jokey oh yeah yeah it was it was
meant to be human you were being racist
in the nature of the way you were no no
and I wasn't saying it to a black person
yeah that right yeah but but in
retrospect problem wise to have said it
I totally accept uh and I guess one of
these people had sent that to patreon uh
and patreon like oh well you're not
allowed to have your patreon anymore
okay but I didn't actually violate you
terms of service because I didn't post
any of that on the platform or nor was
on my channel in fact the person whose
Channel it was on was a really small
YouTuber yeah so it's a tiny and the
audio wasn't great like it was yeah
you'd have to really go out every way to
find it right uh but that was it and and
then there was a huge reaction to that
actually you know Sam Harris closed his
patreon and yeah you know Jordan
Peterson's at the think spot you set up
locals and it was just like it was a
massive thing it was really heartening
to see as well yeah there were loads of
people like no actually you know you
can't just ruin people right you can't
and you were basically making your
living from that at that point right
right so you have a family you got four
kids the whole thing they just take you
out basically overnight and yeah for me
I mean I started Jordan and I we were
working on the thing spot thing and then
Jordan obviously got ill but that's what
led to locals which led obviously to a
lot of other success in Rumble so that
you're allowed to say whatever you want
on this shows which is pretty sweet
um but now you see it you referenced it
earlier now your government as we speak
is coming after uh Russell Brand and for
rumble I put sending out a letter to
pressure them to say that a guy who just
has allegations against him should not
be able to make a living it's psychotic
but what we've been through this again
I mean at least in my case the
government didn't come for me you know
at least in my case it was just Conte
over in California who decided oh I'll
just take this executive action to have
a sitting MP right using the authority
of a government committee to it wasn't
just rumbly there was Tick Tock Twitter
and Facebook and who knows why YouTube
just uh you know we I don't know that
there's something left to YouTube well
YouTube did it already but I think I
guess I guess YouTube was just or they
knew YouTube was going to play ball
right right yeah but the point is that's
I mean that's literally against the
Magna Carta that's the against the very
spirit and principle of common law and
it's staggering that that person hasn't
resigned yet right at the time of
recording that person hasn't resigned I
mean maybe they will have done by the
end of this but it's it's just so beyond
the pale and that's a member of the
conservative party you know so they've
they've brought into because I mean I
don't know what the allegations against
Russell Brand whether they're true or
not you know it's a moot point exactly
it's irrelevant right because okay well
then if he's found guilty there will be
a punishment prescribed under the law
that great then he can be punished you
know as far as I'm aware there are no
charges against him yet you know which
makes this all all the worse because I
mean he's he's alleged it's really just
a very very aggressive rumor that is
being spread about him you know there
are no legal charges and I know a little
something about your tabloids they do
make things up they right is that fair
to say I watched the crown I know what
they did to Diana and then Martin Bashir
the guy who did it then became a huge
star on MSNBC in America the the
tableaus do have a habit of having to
retract a lot yes
um the BBC as well in fact so yes it's
entirely possible these are not true and
uh or exaggerated and misinterpreted
something like this I don't know like I
said I have no idea
um but the point that you're making is
exactly right this is mad this is Way
Beyond The Pale
even if he is convicted for all the
things they that still doesn't mean he
should have his livelihood taken away
from him
it's so profoundly psychotic it would be
the equivalent of a guy who sells shoes
for a living going to a grocery store
and stealing an apple and then YouTube
saying to him you can't work anymore and
somehow the shoe store agreeing with it
like it really but but do you see this
as like like this is the fight more than
anything like the online fight now is
all we've got left right otherwise
everybody's going to turn into an NBC an
NPC it it it's
it's about the legitimacy of you as a
person right that's what it is so look
do I get to have an internet access
account on the internet do I get to
engage in society with everyone else or
should there be a particular privilege
class and everyone else literally
reduced to being a basket case you know
who can't get you know a bank account or
a YouTube account or whatever a Twitter
account you know is that a just society
and the conservative will say no
everyone actually is a kind of unique
human being who's a part of this
tapestry that we call society and even
okay if they do something wrong then we
have a law that prescribes what the
punishment for that wrongdoing is and
that's as far as it goes you know we
don't ruin them because of course the
conservatives think well people can
learn their mistakes learn from their
mistakes and change and actually it's
not right to destroy someone because
essentially it's kind of like a digital
death penalty that they're trying to
give Russell Brand it's like hey he
hasn't even been convicted and even if
he is guilty there are punishments for
it what do you think the end game for
them would be not for a guy okay so you
scare the hell you maybe destroy Russell
Brand and you go for the people that are
backing him and the tech that backs it
and all that which is clearly what this
is about you know you know the day
before that the the Russell thing went
out there was a massive hit piece about
Rumble and the guardian yeah then yeah
then the the uh the piece comes out from
the House of Commons like it's just like
it's just so obvious like we've been
through this before but what do you
think the end game is like okay you can
take out a Russell Brand you can take
out a Tucker Carlson you can take out
whoever you can take you can take out
Carl you can take out Dave but if you
take out millions of people who can't
participate in society like what do they
think is going to happen to those people
well maybe it's what they want to happen
to those people they're definitely going
for total control right it's definitely
about asserting a kind of
internet-wide dominance so they are the
ones who have the authority to say yes
or no which is totally alien to the sort
of English-speaking experience right
because we're used to there being a
strong division between the state and
society and saying no look Society is
pluralistic we all get to have our own
little domains and Gardens and we get to
grow our little things and if they grow
and then that's great and if they don't
then that's our fault and it's up to us
right and so Russell Brand again for me
the classical liberal slash conservative
I'm well you know I'm not even a fan of
Russell Brand I remember Russell Brown
being on TV and it was really annoying
really I said we covered this the other
day I was like I don't know that I've
ever seen a movie of his I I've
interviewed him and I like him a lot I
really do now and it's been fun seeing
his Evolution that you know we're
referencing earlier but in Britain
Russell Brown's been famous for about 25
years right the before before we have
the internet and so you had four
channels on TV right and Russell Brand
would be on one of them and he'd be
really annoying all right because he was
you know a young man who was just a
brussel brand and so I was never a fan
right
um but the but the point is that's fine
I don't need to be a fan of his right I
don't need to be a fan I don't need to
have anything to do with him or anything
that he does it's meant to be a free
Society he can grow his YouTube channel
his Rumble Channel his Twitter whatever
he should be able to go out and do and
say whatever he likes and if I feel the
need to criticize him or contradict him
I should have my domain from where I can
do that as well and that's what a
pluralistic society actually looks like
but that of course is not what they're
creating and you are right that What's
um what's the CEO of rumble's name uh
Chris pavlowski yeah I mean that
genuinely he's a great yeah he's a great
human being to turn around and give the
UK government just that kind of response
takes genuine courage because everyone
can see there is a kind of network of
power that is above the national level
at this point uh I I don't know what
people want to call it like the world
economic Forum or anything like that
like but there is clearly some kind of
international network of power that is
left wing and it wants to have complete
managerial control of the society down
to the everything that you do from every
level it wants that and it's trying to
get it and that's why when um when there
were competitors to Subs to patreon that
popped up they instantly got pulled it's
like no we're not having that no and
that's what they're going to try and do
with Rumble if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell